how's it going everybody
so Avengers 4 is right around the corner
we have the official countdown that's
already started so we know the date that
it's going to come out May 3rd 2019 and
obviously something that is spoken about
a lot with this movie are deaths mainly
people are wondering if Captain America
and/or Iron Man is going to die
some people say Iron Man some people say
Captain America
some people say both but are they
perhaps doing a little bit of
foreshadowing at the end of age of
Ultron I think that they might be and
I'll explain to you why also I still
have a giveaway going right now giving
away a copy of Avengers infinity war art
of the movie art book along with
infinity war Deadpool 2 or ant-man and
the wasp on blu-ray and some special
edition posters all you have to do to
enter for your chance to win is
subscribe to my channel like the video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
let's take a look at this final scene in
age of Ultron that man has no regard for
lawn maintenance I'm gonna miss him
though and you're gonna miss me it's
gonna be a lot of manful tears
I will miss you Tony yeah well it's time
for me to tap out if this should take a
page at a Barton's book they'll pepper a
farm hope nobody blows it up a simple
life you get there one day
I don't know family stability guy wanted
all that went in the ice 75 years ago I
think someone else came out
you all right
I'm home
does this sort of seem like Captain
America is going to die and Ironman is
going to live Marvel is known for doing
foreshadowing like this they plan out
everything super far in advance they
planned on introducing Thanos and the
infinity war movies even before the
first Avengers movie came out and then
they finally introduced him in the post
credit scene in the Avengers
years before infinity war would even
come out and then we would see him again
in age of Ultron and guardians of the
galaxy again both years before infinity
war and Avengers floor would even come
out so they've been planning infinity
war in Avengers 4 for many many years
and let's focus on some of the words
that Captain America and Iron Man say in
this scene Tony starts off by saying
that the Avengers are going to miss each
other and there's going to be a lot of
manful tears but then he starts talking
about finally retiring living the simple
life and then Tony tells captain that
he'll eventually get there too but
captain doesn't seem to think that he's
ever going to stop or ever retire this
conversation actually says a lot about
their characters and a lot about whether
they're going to die or not in Avengers
4 we know that Chris Evans and Robert
Downey jr. x' contracts are up and they
have not renewed to do more so that's
where all the speculation came that
they're either going to die or retire
which makes sense because they're not
going to play big roles moving forward
in the MCU
so it makes sense that they could either
die or retire and according to this
conversation Tony wants to retire Steve
doesn't it's not in Steve's nature to
want to retire the love of his life died
and apparently the Steve Rogers that
wanted to settle down and have a wife
and kids died too when he went in the
ice but Tony has pepper and it's widely
believed that him and pepper will
actually have a child in Avengers 4 so
since he has his family he'll most
likely want to retire after the final
battle in Avengers 4 and I wouldn't
really think that Disney's going to kill
somebody off that has a wife and child
however you never really know but it's
clearly stated here that Steve doesn't
ever see himself retiring even after the
events of civil war where he's basically
wanted by the whole entire world he
doesn't stop he continues to do missions
as The Secret Avengers so it's just not
in his character to retire so that means
an
to take Steve Rogers out of the picture
in the MCU and past the mantle of
Captain America down he'll have to die
otherwise he would just continue to be
Captain America forever essentially and
the way that him and Tony are talking in
this scene at the end of age of Ultron
does seem like eventually there is going
to be a goodbye of some sort and what it
seems like now is that that goodbyes
going to be permanent as Captain America
will probably die in Avengers 4 seems
like they've been building it up for a
pretty long time since age of Ultron and
probably even before after all he is the
First Avenger and is the most likely to
sacrifice himself to save somebody else
but this is just my personal theory what
do you all think about this of course I
don't want him to die but I think he
probably will and I think they've been
hinting at this for a long time now but
let me know what you think in the
comments down below and don't forget to
subscribe comment and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway and stay up
to date on everything relating to
Avengers 4 thank you all so much for
watching we'll fluff
[Music]